all right man bootleg kept podcast we
got a special guest here
uh from the uh dope as usual podcast yes
sir now do you go by Thomas Yola
dopasiola what is your um I I introduce
myself as Thomas to everybody okay but
people call me anything man people call
me a bunch of different things so I man
it's crazy because I was not really hip
to
like the weed YouTube world it's there
until recently oh really very recently
oh yeah and I'm like world listen I'm
pretty heavily involved in the weed [__]
you know so like it was just kind of
I've been to like a lot of seshes and
stuff and I feel like I've met a lot of
people but I wasn't very hip until
recently Travis Thompson came on our
show and he came right after he left
your thing
and uh and you should like he was like
dude this dude just got me high as [__]
I try not to come too high though just
because I knew he was coming and it was
crazy because I was like oh [__] and
then I followed your guys's podcast page
that day
and then
you guys did Jeezy and like your [__]
just kept popping up and then I just
went on a [__] Deep dive because I
really like the way your guys's podcast
is presented the way it looks
is your boy Marty handle all that yeah
Mari mimar do everything he's a beast
dude he's awesome
um but it's a great show like I really
like went on like a
a [__] Bender like just watching some
of your stories thank you that's it and
uh I was like damn this dude's [__]
got a sick life
yeah I don't think about it that way a
lot often but if I do that shit's wild
so for I mean you're obviously you're
from Merced right Merced California
shout out to GB we had GB on the show
before yeah shout out to GB just got the
Merced like the philanthropist award
from the city two days he's a great guy
bro all right he was just recording here
last week uh sweet guy man
um we also had another kid from Merced
on the show the 16 year old kid I met at
little Russell's house
yeah he's a rapper from Merced with
dreads glasses he's like the next kid
he's incredible so I've I've met him at
the Russell's house no [__] and I was
like so mesmerized by his freestyle or
whatever he did on stage at the
Russell's house I was like bro you got
to come to LA and rap on my show really
him and his dad came on a school day
on a school day it was [__] sad
that's awesome
um and I'm actually on the radio in
uh
in it's not much okay Modesto Modesto
yep yeah what's the station it's like
hot I think hot 1047. I think that's the
station I'm on hot 104 105 now I'm on
the Hip Hops or whatever the Rhythm oh
[__] yeah yeah that's right that's the
only uh that's the only Outlet we have
in town is the radio man shout out to
Merced man Merced dude that's the most
the drive through anyone it's a
drive-through city is it it is what you
got you need drugs that's the spot you
stop on the way to L.A because they got
cookies there right in the lemonade or
is it just is there and none of that I'm
sometimes dispensary-wise honestly no I
think there is I think there's I think
there's a cookies there I've never been
to a dispensary in my town ever why
would you well I just I've just never
been it popped up in the last three or
four years and honestly I don't really
go to all dispensaries here I mean
neither do I yeah all the weed I get is
free so I just I like to I get that much
free weed from people every day but I
just buy there's just certain weeds I
buy what is your go-to like strain like
you're you preferred it's non-existent
right now but the gaseous OG's on the
planet is all I want to smoke sure OG
guys every day in my sleep if I can't
find it well it's kind of crazy because
like oh geez have kind of died out right
where it was kind of like what eight or
nine years ago every rapper was off the
OG I would buy a pound every month and
I'd smoke it throughout the month right
and I was happy and then I got a pound
and went what is this [__] Fool's
Gold yeah get burned with that tastes
like sulfur you got me and then I got
another two packs and I went are you
[__] kidding I just wasted my money
it's like almost like the Exotics have
just taken over to the point where it's
like in candy yeah it's like anything
candy takes over this I bought a pea
this is lemon I've been smoking this
lemon and it's so fire so you're still
buying uh you're still buying I mean you
as much free weed as you get oh I I
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings but
I will try your weed
and I give it to all my homies because
then they don't got to buy weed they
don't gotta do [__] hey Cyrus how much
weed do I give you every [__] week
yeah give me so much weed and I'm like
first of all a lot of the [__] is
whatever right yeah
yeah it comes a cool bag I just feel bad
like I have two Zips here like full here
take some I'm not gonna smoke that for
at least two weeks yeah you know what I
mean for sure yeah or my sister my dad
my dad is my dad's in town right now I
just lace him I'm like take all this
[__] let's be hyped oh yeah like uh
Jardine in Las Vegas they give me like
store credit every month so I'll go to
Vegas and I'll just be like Dad what do
you want because they sponsor a park yes
shout out to Heart they just hit us up
they're great guys I was wondering who I
was wondering if I moved out of Vegas
yeah who are you talking to uh Mario's
handling that that they're great guys
yeah cool [__] with them I've never been
to any of this I've only been to hardine
is the one it's like you walk in and
it's like the it's like the Rolls Royce
of dispensaries they have their own
scent it's like a signature scent they
got their own shoes they they do they
drop their own feelers
they're all set no I swear to God and
you can buy bored me like yo what do we
need
we need people to smell like us what the
[__] so good we had the candles but we
ran out of them because you you like the
candy and now it smells like Jardine
that's amazing bro do they grow there
too at the spot no they're strictly they
do not just grow yeah they're strictly
retail because I feel like a lot of
people who try to go full vertical they
end up [__] out of business or or
just never that great yeah the overturn
of employees and goes I don't care about
this crop like I'm gonna get paid today
that's a lot so they're strictly retail
yeah and then they're doing like a
they've got some big plans I can't see
what they're doing but they got some big
planes it's Vegas you know yeah
um so okay so you grew up in Merced yep
we have very so I was watching you talk
about your family situation and I feel
like we have very similar
human beings around us as we were
growing up yeah where'd you grow up I
grew up in Phoenix oh God you're just
looking at me a terrible area of Arizona
I grew up in an area called Sunny Slope
which was like Hell's Angels ran it was
[__] calling the Central Valley it
was like it was like Mexicans and Hells
Angels ran my area and all my [__]
family members were [__] fiend out
you know what I'm saying shout out to my
mom she wasn't but my dad had his little
issues with crack for a little bit you
know what I'm saying
um my uncles were all Tweakers all my
cousins are in and out of prison and it
was funny because I related to your
story about for people who don't know
you're
mom ended up with a
person who went to prison and came out
as like a white supremacist he survived
oh no he was there he was already oh he
was already there oh yeah when I met him
I was like Mom this is the guy you're
dating right he's gonna get a shot well
it's crazy because I have a cousin named
Aaron God rested so he passed away in
prison maybe like seven years ago but
him and my cousin Sheldon Sheldon is
still alive in prison right now but he's
Mexican Mafia so in Arizona it's like
Mexican Mafia right in an Aryan Nation
in prison yeah but these two guys are
the same age so they grew up causing
hell together
in Phoenix and then they ended up both
in the system but they ended up both in
the system on offices opposite sides
right so nobody ever knew they were
related so my cousin Aaron gets out of
PR because my cousin Sheldon looks like
a [__] cholo like his whole entire
body's tattooed he's [__] you would
never know he's half white ever
um my cousin Aaron he was running uh the
white side in prison
when he got out of prison for like a cup
of coffee and I took him to a Busta
Rhymes concert
and he [__] because he loved hip-hop
yeah he couldn't Love Hip Hop yeah 100
so we go to this [__] Busta Rhymes
concert and he was just having the time
of his [__] life like knows all the
lyrics and I'm like what and I had to
like when we went
had to wear his whole I was like oh come
on yeah cover that [__] up yeah because
he had all the tattoos and [__] but I
related to that because you had said
that you're
your stepdad was not necessarily racist
only racist and he explained it to me
because my best friend was black yeah
and his dad was the big you ever watch
UFC yeah remember Marvin beastman
Eastman the little short dude yeah his
older brother is my best friend's dad
and he's six four
built like the Rock and there's my
stepdad built like Edward Norton in
America I mean he was a monster
but he explained it to me because I
remember I brought him over one day and
then my head of thought
are you is this gonna be okay I never
got that vibe from him but I remember
thinking thinking about it and he told
me when he left he goes I don't know if
you know like I love him that's like my
kid it's your best friend I gotta act
like that in jail so I can come back
home he didn't explain everything to me
until I was about 13. my mom and him got
divorced and then
we want like a a tweaker camping trip
which is just laying in the in the in
the field next to the trailers and like
he dug a hole in the side of the
mountain so we could sit like in a couch
he's like that's what I used to do I
didn't have a house and all this crazy
[__] tell me I throw knives that weekend
and uh
it's just weird man it's weird because I
always think I just because I just
brought him up I haven't seen him in 12
years and then I just saw him on a
arrest report
and wow like he looks like those monster
Tweakers in jail oh yeah no teeth yeah
strung out yeah I got a few of them that
was in my family yeah that was my kind
of like my dad for eight years plus
right yeah my dad was on drugs and never
cared so
like here's my stepdad everybody's like
he's a bad guy I'm like
in certain places he is yes he's fully
covered except uh stops here stops here
and stops here how egregious are the
tattoos though are they lightning bolts
are they swastika bolts swashed because
oh he's got the whole [__] things all
over his head
uh White is right was hella big on his
body and I always ask him like what is
that the first time I asked him like
what is that
and then he explained like what racism
is in prison yeah yeah he was like he
had to give you that like breakdown of
like I had to survive my sister's Brown
as [__] well in in Cali I think the
Mexicans and the whites are kind of
excellent Spanish and [__] he told me a
lot about it I mean I can't obviously
talk about what he talked to me about
but he's down with them yeah he's down
he spoke flu in Spanish
taught me some [__] which is the
funniest thing I've ever said to people
I told that to Dr Drew and that's when I
realized like
that is stupid
it's white supremacists taught me
Spanish because you don't speak Spanish
Flu all right yeah the whole family
sucks they never taught me [__] that's
funny but they'd make fun of me for not
speaking it but they never taught me so
it's like you didn't [__] teach me
bro
come on it's not my fault it's my mom's
uh have to shoot my grandma's Jewish my
other grandma's my grandpa was from is
uh from Texas and Mexican right so like
half my family's white Jewish people
other half my family's Mexican as hell
and uh I don't speak Spanish so they're
really like white boy I'm like you check
some boxes for sure and I was this color
until I was like 12. and then I don't
know what happened one summer at
football I just turned brown you just
filled out yeah it was a trip dude so um
give me a little bit of your background
before we get to your podcast and [__]
like how did you because you used to
[__] like you used to [__] with the
packs back in the day yeah yeah I never
shipped nothing though
I I got one box ready and the guy flaked
and I went this is a sign for me not to
do this yeah
because I like I I spent so much [__]
doing the you know [__] vacuum
ceiling triple vacuum ceiling double bag
whatever and he wanted like eight
different things I went and bought them
all and then he just stopped he just
flaked I'm like bro this is my sign to
just sell packs in person like I've been
doing for 20 years or 15 years so would
you just like middleman [__]
I think everybody's another man the
middleman game is popping in La man it's
crazy I wasn't that guy yeah you know
there's that guy yeah sorry for I'm
sweating my I was just I think it's the
ibuprofen or something it might be
something my bad um you look like it's a
lot hotter in here than it is it's not
you guys are fine I'm just like
I'm sipping hot tea right now I know
damn dude nah like I said they're
sweating like a horn in church yeah I
hurt my back though I think that might
be that might be the thing
um yeah it's crazy because like moving
to La like like just the weed economy is
so wild here and none of them are from
L.A none of them well yeah you're right
I mean are the fools openly and you'll
note and like it's crazy because you'll
notice like a lot of like the plugs or
whatever out here are
there's a lot of Asian folks there's a
lot of Armenian folks it's all colors
it's a wild uh economy in La still that
is still thriving like if you just go
down to downtown L.A
all those high rises are like
so live in those
yeah it's just like there's just trap
houses in all of them well my thing is
like I'm just glad I'm like in my head I
know I'm a good person right I'm like I
could have robbed you could have robbed
you could have robbed you could have
robbed you pay attention yeah people
through my hallways like you got back
bags under your arm from Target I'm
gonna follow your [__] apartment if I
was a piece of [__] yeah and what am I
gonna do I'm gonna take all your [__]
yeah all these fools are so careless
posting snaps posting where they're
eating dinner it's like full fools are
gonna shoot you and take your [__] yeah
I can follow you in two days two posts I
got you a lot of these guys want to be
rappers man that's what it is that cloud
is a drug man oh I fools are crazy the
best drug dealers I ever met don't drive
wild cars and they don't have social
media facts and they're still crushing
factuals but like on
well like we talked about earlier about
places you know yeah I was like
[__] like that yeah those are the fools
you don't expect the fools that are just
with it well you said that you had told
so for full discrepancy so you had you
had said that when you walked up here
that you had told a story about our new
location in one of your I don't care if
you share it but yeah in one of your
previous pods I couldn't believe it one
of your story times yeah because I've
heard so for people who don't know
obviously recently we moved into a new
facility in LA
and I've heard this before we got here
we knew it was a dispensary of sorts
right
so when we moved in we had to do a lot
of work we had to fix it up it was the
[__] pain in the ass but I've had two
or three people be like yo man I used to
[__] pull up and get work at your
spot before you had it obviously yeah so
right when I walked in I went huh and
then where I got to the back go oh this
is a nice little air and then that's
when it hit me because I said that when
I walked up like this is a nice spot
like I like that you're not getting in
here without getting shot over the fence
like Christmas Story wow like you're not
gonna make it in here right but right
when I walked in the back I got a crazy
memory
oh yeah for all those fans out there
that watch my stories
there's a certain weed Hub I talked
about and this was it that's when you
said there used to be a wall there I
[__] knew it because it was different
because I remember walking hitting the
right and then he just sat me in a room
where I watched a little square TV for a
while
I think it was
Mori or Jesus or Jerry Springer but it
was only like a TV just out of the 90.
out of 96 drug dealer what year was this
was this like in 2014. I don't know 15.
wow yeah that's not too long ago
so it's yeah good trip bro yeah used to
be a lot of fire in these buildings
right here 100
um okay so at what point in time did you
start to kind of
pivot out of like full-time trapping
um what happened was that I started
Instagram and uh I thought it was fun
started getting a little following and I
thought ah this is where I go to jail or
I'd be smiling with pounds right right
right right that's just like
that's a dart board and some DEA guy's
office like no I like this kid yeah
right because I was supposed to 100
packs like laying in them because it was
fun right
and then I realized like you know what I
gotta stop when I got a homie hit me up
and he told me that these fools were
like all right so you know how you're
going on that trip he's off this person
this person this person already plotted
out how they're gonna come into your
spot
if you leave or not
you know what I mean like oh [__] I know
these gangbanger ass fools people were
like plotting on you yeah just because
once my [__] got kind of big my Town's
80 000. this was in Merced still yeah
okay
uh so I just stopped I was like you know
it's not even worth this [__] yeah plus
like everybody in their mom sells
[__] weed now everybody does
everybody back then I'm like
the fools I was giving you peace to now
we're like oh now that I get a pee I'm
just gonna buy it from that guy because
it's 200 cheaper undercut yours I'm like
oh you bastards but my shit's fire but
there was a time where I looked in my
cabinet
and I had like six pounds of forum
cookies I couldn't get rid of it really
and I was like nobody wants the fire
right like no I got it over here for 19
like 19.
my heart just dropped like bro I got
this for 27. no I gotta get two for 36.
yeah this isn't gonna work anymore
that's all I thought like merced's too
small I'm done and I just like focused
on the content started to push trees
what is push trees it's my clothing
company okay I started that like uh
2014. end of no end of 13.
and that [__] took off really really
really well like it just shocked me yeah
and then I thought you know what let me
just stop the weed but I I told my my
fiance now like we're gonna be broke for
a while like are you down and she was
down and we were broke for seven [__]
years straight dude that's crazy but
making content like making content for I
just do it for free I didn't realize you
get paid for sure for all this
influencer [__] yeah so I was just
making content to have fun was this on
YouTube or on Instagram I didn't start
YouTube till like the end of 2018
probably so this was Instagram Instagram
yeah but I'm on my 30th Instagram
account like they they won't they keep
[__] your [__] up they won't stop so
my first page was huge like Rihanna what
it was Rihanna would like all my toy
pictures all the time and people would
[__] go crazy and that's how I got a
lot of the mainstream world and not the
weed World watching my [__] and then you
say toys you mean like you have a toy
collection
yeah yeah but no I would do like uh I
started off doing movie scenes oh with
snugs and toys oh you watch Reservoir
Dogs yeah of course Marvin Nash gets his
ear cut off yeah I did that I went to
Hobby Lobby about a little chair put a
nug and it's before videos I just took
like collage pictures almost like a
stop-motion almost yeah yeah and it was
just like
Rambo Forrest Gump I just did all my
favorite movies and people just they
loved four hours to do these little
pictures and Rihanna was in she was
lovely love toy pictures and that's back
when like think so and so liked this
post and there was that other page you
can look at it yeah
I'm glad they'd remove that me too and
that [__] was dumb that's a lot of uh
people lost their relationships too and
relationships and relationships but we
connect a lot went away right there like
that's the guy oh yeah
oh that's the guy yeah that was it then
kick came and fools were like hey I'll
sell [__] to you and Vine oh [__] the
Wee World Went weird the Wee World
winner went meme well now everybody's on
like signal and uh what's the other one
program telegram yeah yeah I don't know
I'm good and uh yes I was just selling
packs I was like you know what let's
go full time on the content and I was
barely making my rent with push trees so
that was enough every month just to
cover my [__]
it was the worst man it really was the
[__] worst but like I was happy as
hell all the time and the coolest job
ever that barely hate me but I only got
paid because I made a company but I
didn't get paid off views I never got
paid off views like YouTube still well I
mean I'm sure a lot of your content is
not monetizable it was monetized for
three years but you know that little bar
which shows your money mine was
transparent but it had the money
and I never got it what I've talked
about the lawyer I've talked to that do
ddg yeah talk to Hank is a big YouTuber
talk to DJ ghost they're like what are
you saying to me and I showed him like I
thought you're a [__] line like no
look look it
did you apply for monetization it was
monetized so you like you got approved
approved like you got the Google AdSense
I have a Google AdSense up to my bank
account and every month it just says
zero in the Google AdSense but on
YouTube it you could see a number and
there's just a nut waiting for you to
get paid I mean one day if anybody else
say it now if anybody can give me my
money I will give you 30 of it it's
almost it's 3.1 million dollars just
sitting there I never got it why [__]
they kept it they were running ads on
all my [__] about age restricted and
then they were running
Ross and press ads on my videos that I
can't
on my rosin press video they were
running rosin press ads wait what year
was the rosin press thing 2019 oh yeah
this is crazy so there was like a big
Purge I got I got YouTube a year after
because I heard about the YouTube Purge
which was like yeah which was about 17.
yeah exactly or 16. I heard about that
but I was like bro I just can't tell
can't we get paid
and then they like yo we'll pick up some
contacts at YouTube please help me heck
I'll help you bro I will I swear to God
you can take 25 to 30 of this chunk of
money if you can give me my money back
just because it's like you know I don't
think it's that hard of a fix we'll buy
something with it we just want to buy
some property yeah that's a that's a
that's a lot of money
dude I try not to get mad every time you
log into YouTube you're looking at it
like no about two years ago they stopped
it and it just said zero zero oh so
there's is there any last year said
monetize is gone
but I mean it was Monitor and they were
running Donald Trump uh ads on my [__]
for president
I never got no money from that what the
[__] that shit's insane intervention or
uh rehab ads all the time on my [__]
it's crazy crazy yeah I got a second
Channel that I don't smoke or cuss and
they they just demonetize that too
really it's a drug content
okay what about your podcast Channel
demonetized really every every episode's
age restricted and when you when you try
to press it it says are you sure you
want to watch this this is this is a
concept yesterday I clicked one and said
this contains suicidal content the 80
one I just did yeah
have you considered uh well I wouldn't
say not smoking because we have smoke we
have episodes of people smoking it's
monetized have you considered
editing out curse words for the first
like 10 minutes we have a 10 guy nice oh
I've seen that many of you guys do have
that
nothing
now bet pixels the people that help out
all the comedians they were like brah
they were trying to help and they never
I wonder if they just have like a I have
a Blacklist on my name they might have
100 dude because I've gotten the lead
off of Vimeo the video which was like
the old school like via Vimeo
or if you were like a video editor you'd
post your reels on or you we got kicked
off of that for promoting the sale of
drug content or the sale of drugs and
harmful Goods what I don't even know you
can get kicked off that that [__] is
crazy I get [__] with a lot dude look
a lot so
I saw recently that you're picking up a
sponsors on your podcast yeah we just
opened up to we sponsors finally because
I never did because I wanted to show
YouTube like look I can be the podcast
guy too I don't have to be the weed guy
on here
so there's there's a lot of episodes we
don't even smoke because I asked the
guests do you smoke no do you mind if I
smoke well I don't mind like don't worry
I'm not gonna even box you don't worry
we won't even smoke there's a lot of
episodes we don't smoke I was gonna say
uh and they're interested so at the
moment you guys haven't been able to
really fully monetize the podcast I know
you guys had like a a small deal because
I saw some episode where you were
talking about how
um you were working with was it a
network yeah we signed with uh a company
they do like say it's this compound yeah
so here's our set there's Tyson there's
Matt Barnes there's Tony Hawk and like
we walk in do our sh it's like a TV
thing it just didn't work out that's all
nothing bad just me and Marty looked at
each other how long is that deal
indefinite and then we were like at
three months we're like
Marty we can work way harder and faster
than this and he's like I know
so we're like hey guys we're just gonna
go back and do our thing we appreciate
you we left nothing wrong on their part
just if me and Marty's Marty Works
harder than I do and I work my ass off
and it's just if we can do this
let's just do it ourselves is your squad
a two-man Squad it's just me Marty dude
so Marty handles the editing he handles
editing
the back end stuff so he's like
uploading he's uh um yeah yeah he's
uploading the if we see a social media
clip he's handling that as well yeah
Marty's completely taken over the
podcast since we left the agency and
came back so he's just on it he's doing
a great job he's doing a great [__]
job dude I just go hosting yeah Marty's
just the man bro he really is uh do you
know about Marty or no I just followed
him once I kind of um dived into your
world and I saw he you know he's like I
got a Graphics Company and but he's able
guy in the world
um I met Marty so he does graphics for
Joe Rogan and Shannon yeah he DM me and
I went for real because he hit me up one
day and goes I had her in one of my
story times ago was this would you guys
watch a podcast if I did one right it's
like 2019 I said it yeah
and then I got a bunch of comments
saying [__] yeah I'd watch it all right
that day I posted it Marty dm'd me
and said hey I do podcasting this and
that and this I've been following you
about five years but I saw and that's
what made me happy like oh you didn't
just bug me and say let's work yeah like
what the [__] do you I do Roofing like
shut up that doesn't help right now
you're gonna be like people do that to
you I get I guarantee oh yeah yeah but
Marty's like I do podcasting I just
watched your video five minutes ago and
I'm like if you ever want to start and
then Marty's like uh ticket sales
Graphics promo online [__] for Rogan
theovan and Corolla but he helped start
the fighter and the kid so he's like the
guy oh he helped start that helped he
helped with my friends
yeah and then so I'm looking at him like
you want to help me start a [__] pie
I just get high on the internet yeah you
know
and um it took a long time he started he
took over my YouTube videos Marty's the
best editor on YouTube I will say that
right now he crushes me your videos are
sick Bro the production value
marketing is crazy I'm like dude you
guys are kind of running circles around
a lot of thank you man
and again like I said I was very
ignorant to your uh podcast
so it was dope to like when I saw the
Trap I was like yo this podcast looks
sick I love your guys's [__] sad
thank you and then I followed you guys
and I was like uh uh when the Jeezy
thing popped up I watched that and I
just loved your your approach I loved
your non-hip-hop approach to that
interview yeah I wanted to bring out
like what else did people not ask you
because the thing is is like Jeezy's
gonna run around and do every hip hop
podcast and they're gonna approach him
on the hip-hop side and you approached
him just wanted some life [__] like hey
I checked your book out like I I always
want to ask I asked a lot of guests if
16 year old you walks in are they gonna
beat the [__] out of you or you got them
right because that gets gas going what
and then it goes makes them reflect and
they go
I was wild and then it makes I feel like
it breaks the ice of like
hey you know we're nice we're chilling
you just talk because you know a lot of
famous [__] do a lot of interviews
and a lot of people are very uh you know
they're especially a guy like Jeezy
Jeezy's probably got his guard up in a
lot of interviews because he's [__]
Jeezy I can't always see when it goes
down yes it's about minute five you
gotta ease him in yep yeah that's what
we try to do here because like obviously
we're a hip-hop podcast but like we
aren't like other platforms where I
would say that like
we're not a controversy driven oh no
this week and I didn't we didn't mention
yeah controversy at all so it's like it
you know
I won't say like we just had Adam 2200
Adam 22 challenged A.D on our [__] he
went hard yeah he did but the thing is
like I'm friends with both of them so
like I'm trying to kind of like I mean I
don't think I don't know what's going to
happen would you do that in real life no
he wouldn't [__] hey you guys should
you guys should box you know what he
said about you so I'm not gonna do it on
my show also like I feel if I can just
do well and do everything without that
I mean it kind of like stamps the like
nah good conversation people just kind
of want to watch I'm like yeah so would
you attribute because you have a big
following
um would you attribute that to
uh Instagram the clothing line or the
YouTube channel because your other
YouTube channel is really big yeah so
that's that's what happened I started
2018 I got deleted on Instagram for like
15th time and I'm gonna try YouTube
should I just [__] try it because I
had posted a video like once every eight
months on YouTube but it was just clips
from my iPhone that I didn't care about
because I cared about Instagram
and then I really liked it and I never
talked on camera until 2018.
I never talk I just do weed videos and I
did something called story time I was I
was with my girlfriend like hey you
think people want us to do a story they
could tell a story like I could talk
yeah and I set my phone up and I'm like
I always started selling weed boom
that's kind of interesting and I just
talked and it went [__] insane and
when I watched it back as I was editing
it
I kept forgetting it's me and I was just
kind of getting entertained like that
this was crazy like The View High fool
that's you dummy I do that all the time
like this was [__] dumb as I'm tired
as I'm editing
and then I'm like I'll do another one
and that's what blew my channel up to
the max is Story Time alone's got 80
million views on it just on the stories
you know and um
we're restricted we're blacklists have
been deleted off YouTube Marty got my
YouTube back actually they deleted me at
9.95 then I the day I hit a million they
deleted me what the fell strikes no
nothing no anything someone doesn't like
me bro you're not [__] with you you
truly don't like me I think they're like
that smile's fake
or something maybe they [__] hate me
I don't know maybe I
you know those times where people ask
you come on man what'd you do something
right oh yeah you know what I mean I
can't really truly honestly think of
like well I've never [__] anybody over
what okay what did I do did I [__]
somebody at YouTube's girl back in the
day not even somebody's asked me that
I'm like
no that's insane yeah so I really don't
know what it is I did I had a DEA thing
on me for a little bit maybe it's a
government thing
maybe don't know
obviously they were wrong and I didn't
go to jail so I'm sure was that the
closest you've ever been to
incarceration no
no I've uh have you ever have you ever
been locked up or no there's a lot of
instances where I was like well that's
it [__] I'm finally gonna see what it's
like in there huh
and I swear to God like on some Truman
Show [__] they're like no producers call
this fool tell them to [__] let him
go wow I swear to God there's been times
I'm like I got six pounds of shatter in
my back seat and pizza boxes I'm done
right I'm pulled over I think it's the
smile and the customer service voice you
gotta go customers hi sir oh no no
problem sir I'll be right here hands are
always on the steering wheel my wallet's
right there do you want me is it cool if
I get it here you go but you take it out
I'm always so polite and I don't know
what it is I didn't have my ID the last
time I got pulled over I forgot my
wallet
you have a Jewish last name or a Latino
last name Latino yeah okay
yeah they're like oh no not at all it's
a nice Goldberg here yes
but uh I I think someone's just like yo
you got five chances and you're gonna
use them all already [__]
so I know so Pax Teamworks I don't care
right but wow
um
yeah there's been a lot of times too
where I just like wow well that was it
this is over and I think of all every
time I'm about to get in trouble I go I
like calculate all the math I'm about to
lose in my car that's all I really care
about at the beginning like
I gotta think of the fire that these
fools are gonna confiscate
and that hurts me more like you guys
aren't gonna do nothing with it it's
gonna burn probably gonna or you're
gonna smoke I had a cop pocket my weed
one time when I was in high College said
he was gonna write and he just stole my
weed I got no ticket that's that's a
that's a that's the best alternative
yeah take the weed man take the weed but
also
it's like this here's 50 bucks or here's
some fire ass weed and it's not worth 50
bucks like I'll take the fire as we I
just don't know what it is like that
trade-off of like there's so much work
went into that [__] weed I don't want
it too much passion
I just think I just love weed a lot uh
what year did you start selling weed
uh
sophomore year
of school
of high school me and my best friend Joe
Fish
this is the first story I ever told I
lived across street from high school so
on Sunday and my mom is a monster she'll
[__] I always compared to Joe Pesci
and Good Fellas she's a monster she'll
[__] beat your ass dude or girl it
doesn't matter right so I was definitely
scared of my mom right that's what kept
me out of gangs in the gang town like my
mom's scary
and I'm like I'm not gonna get caught I
can't smell like weed my mom will
probably stab me or something or hit me
with something so I thought like Joe you
know like we can't get caught so what we
did is we went and stashed because it's
hot and Merced yeah but it still has
drain pipes for the rain times so what I
did is we went and stashed 10 sacks in
certain drain pipes and 20s and certain
drain pipes and then the wood wood shop
that hasn't moved since my mom went
there right we just went and stashed it
and at the school at the school so I
have it on me but I didn't have it on me
that was my thing like I could have it
on me without having it on me
like what do you need ten all right cool
I'll walk the opposite way come around
that hallway because I know someone's
just going to follow me try to watch
where I obsess my [__]
and the first lunch we sold a zip and me
and Joe looked at each other like oh my
[__] god and I was I grew up so poor
I'm like dude I got 40 dollars that's
not bad you know I mean like because the
transaction is ill yeah at the end I'm
like I made 40 profit holy [__]
I was hyped
how do you go from that like like what
is the progression into like
getting into the Pax world because it is
like a culture here in California you
know what I'm saying and then you're
kind of in the mid well not necessarily
in the middle you're more on the
Northern side of the
I mean Redding and we California doesn't
really but you're closer to the Bay I'm
an hour and a half yeah
I'm in between uh in my head I think of
California
San Francisco and L.A that's all you
think of nobody thinks of Sacramento
anymore nobody thinks of like you said
like whatever the [__] where the
Redwoods are yeah you don't think I just
think weed yeah mountain men like did
you ever get into that world where
because I spoke with burn and he told us
this story where
he thought he was gonna die he went to
oh wins the wrong girl yeah well he went
up north or wherever the Emerald
Triangle yeah and he said that uh he
brought somebody up there it's on
YouTube it's got a lot of views it's
kind of crazy benefit from what I hear
that that world is crazy because they
kind of live by their own laws oh
there's certain times where you can't a
lot of my
Mountain homies tell me a lot I don't go
up there so we haven't gone up there oh
I've been here been up there I don't
want to go back but but in your Heyday
you were in your Heyday you would go up
there and no no no so what happens I had
the ultimate [__] connect in Merced
he was my one of my good friend's older
brother and everybody knew like
that that was just the man right 19 he
bought his house
he had a Mercedes like in the poor ass
town like he and he's a white kid and he
could freestyle for 45 minutes straight
and it was always the coolest [__] we'd
get drunk and just listen to him like
how how were you doing you know just
sometimes you see like you don't make
music at all
you're [__] talented wow right and he
was just the coolest guy
and then he had the humble connect the
the rec line he had the directions he
flooded everything and when I started
chilling with him is when I started
making a lot of money and getting packs
so that was I was getting two packs and
breaking them and then from him he's
like here's 20. just pay me back
[__] duffels in my little like 2003
Impala like just just scared to death at
first like someone's gonna rob me and I
thought No One's Gonna rob me they don't
even know I have this [__] yeah yeah
that was the pizza guy I worked at the
pizza spot
and that's how I started that's how I
made a lot of money too I would uh I put
up like a half p in my trunk my scales
and on my deliveries people just hit me
up all day and I just while you were
delivering pizza yeah but I drive I
drive fast all right my dad my whole
family's truck drivers so I know how to
drive I'm trying to sell a little boy
that's cool that's a wild thing he's my
whole family's drunk drivers I had to be
the designated driver as a at a young
age no no they don't drink oh my whole
family's a straight ass like you do
drugs and drink you're a [__] loser
my grandma grandpa are like they Peak
Mexicans okay like they came here with
nothing and they owned like how many
properties I couldn't tell you wait did
you just say though your your family was
drunk drivers or did I did I
misunderstand what you just said they're
all truck drivers Oh I thought I said
drunk drivers no I'm sorry they're all
truck drivers I was like my bad they're
all truck drivers so they all drunk okay
I got it yes I knew how to drive yeah so
I mean and it's my town I know it so I
would just when people hit me up like yo
I need an eighth like perfect I'm taking
a delivery
the thing because it looks like I'm just
I'd walk and sell a sack and leave
that's like some [__] out of a [__]
Workaholics episode or something it was
incredible I'd keep my sign on after
work because who pulls over the pizza
guy nobody I'm telling you all these
things I thought of because I was like
I'm not going to [__] jail that
sounds terrible
well like there's like little things
like uh back in the day that like if you
were to like ship [__] out like I would
do is like I would buy this eBay tape
so there's this eBay tape right it's
blue yeah and I'd be like well
let me tape up the box with eBay tape
because it looks like it's some eBay
[__] you know what I'm saying like
yeah shipping there's some clever people
out there though what's the what's the
what's the like the moment you looked at
someone like how the [__] does your
brain think of this did you ever see the
craziest boxed up I've seen something
I've seen some well I got friends like
currently that will fly with with lots
of work bro and it's kind of
of the break variety
not the weed version no no I've seen
that like are you [__] an informative
and they'll just check the bag with that
in it
a carry-on oh that's crazy hey we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at Odd Socks baby shout out to Odd
Socks man the most comfortable socks in
the world Listen they got all the
licenses if you love chips you know what
I'm saying they got the Funyuns they got
the goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet they also just
introduce their draws that's right we
got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and
you'll save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction or maybe your thing
ain't thinging like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you're asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thanking me your girl will be thanking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview when I say when I
looked in and went say it again what you
just came here with because we were
there and I looked at me
no he's currently not in the country and
and and being looked for so it's it's
not gonna happen I don't have anybody
who's flown with that but I have friends
who actively fly across the country with
like a like 50 packs like in their
luggage in their jacket no no no no no
no no they check it in under the plane
then the purple that work there are
getting paid back no because they the
50p 50p giant [__] suitcases and then
they they just check two bags and then
they'll vacuum seal
certain amount of they get those uh
those laundry vacuum seals
and the way they seal it it'd be like 25
on each side of the bag
and again the liner yeah they're just
[__] filling up a suitcase I mean
kind of but you can't see when you open
it but this is the thing from what I
understand
the X-ray machine sees that as the it's
the same it shows up the same way that
clothing will show up
ah
so you're kind of like playing roulette
that's what I'm saying you're just
hoping that somebody don't crack it open
but it looks like a bunch of clothes
two times I've been searched at the
airport and I had weed in my bag and I
was 15 and I was 18 and I almost ran on
the 15 one but then I thought where am I
going yeah the Portland airport
and I put two Zips in my suitcase and my
dad dropped me off and he was all happy
and she's like yeah you're doing really
good man I got kicked out and had to
move to Oregon
and I had two Zips and then as they're
searching my bag I'm like well that's it
I'm gonna I'm in trouble this is a
federal building yeah it's 15 like oh
it's over they looked over it they open
they searched my bag and everything
didn't even they got to like it was
under a blue striped shirt and I
remember it was like the seventh shirt
down they get there I put remember a
long movies on VHS were two two yeah two
tapes all right so I had the American
Beauty when it was two yeah so I put it
Tuesday yeah I put two Zips in it I was
like ah [__] yeah but I made it they
opened it okay you're good and zipped it
up and like my throw up went back down a
lot of the rappers like when they fly
places where they shouldn't be flying
with weed they'll stuff it in uh
deodorant deodorant sticks
I flew to Mexico with a lot of [__]
um just joints though yeah any time when
I'm saying that now it's it's just for
personal I I don't sell [__] of course
so it's like but personals like four
Zips kind of sometimes yeah and you're
not buying weed in Mexico hell no that's
a wild thing to do oh hell no
I don't know what you're selling me
buddy yeah so I just uh
I was breaking down like little peas in
here and there and then I met my connect
I changed his name is his name's
something else his name is John in the
video yeah you interviewed him right no
no I have a are you interviewed somebody
with a ski mask on yeah that's my other
homie and after the thing I went you
have a ski mask on that's why we could
talk because the [__] we talk about I'm
like this is a move you know what I'm
saying the things you can never talk
about I'm like wow you're alive still
good job bro I I'm happy to see you so
that homie was the most docile interview
of all time because even after he's like
it's just my voice we should have voice
changed you dude man because he's really
into some [__] and I can't there's no
I'd rather not do the episode but I
talked to him about it like the stories
over the 10 years I've known you were
unbelievable the [__] that I see in your
house is [__] you know sometimes you
walk in like oh my God what is in this
house I have a friend like that yeah
it's not that you don't feel safe but if
you didn't know him about am I gonna get
killed in here yeah I've got it I gotta
leave
my very close friends his house is
always
it's very nice but you'll go over there
and you'll be like always very nice like
there's this one time I went over to
someone who's not around anymore but I
went over to my boy's crib
and he had a bunch of tile in his
Workshop
and I was like oh you got a new towel
you know
he's like I know open the top one I
looked down just [__] kilos of
cocaine just stuffed down up [__]
like in the tiles yeah scary
crazy when I see multiple bricks rest in
peace to that guy too by the way he
passed away
it always gives me a bad feeling yeah
like a feeling of like I need to get out
of this place some there's too much
money in this house and that shit's evil
and then you get desensitized to it too
oh yeah it's scary too I mean Coke easy
homies and it's just bad for me so I
don't do it anymore I used to cook all
too [__] yeah I've never I've
actually never done any drugs but weed
and shrooms good I'm so happy for you
keep it that way but because I see my
family you know oh yes my dad was a
[__] crank head my whole life
and have you ever done anything like
crazy like that like oh I've done all
drugs you've done it all done it all
what's your least favorite crack crack
makes you feel disgusting I'm gonna ask
you about that crap it makes you it made
me feel gross because ice I watch
snowfall right and yeah snowfall's great
what a great show and like you know
you'll those are crack heads just the
way I feel about crack is it's it's a I
mean listen most serious drugs people
are willing to
check their sexuality at the door to get
more of it oh yeah there's like grown
straight men offering blow jobs in
America right now for more crack or
fentanyl for sure for sure right so my
thing is is like well crack must be
amazing oh you're talking about the drug
I haven't done heroin acid but crack
crack everyone all right look it when I
smoked it with my Uncle John he he
passed away recently that fool was like
my best homie and
I got him to do Coke for the first time
in his life and he's 11 years older than
me so here I am 15 we smoke weed all the
time together
and I'm like hey man he's like I'll
never put powder in my my nose but he
was smoking crack no he'd never do it
I'm like because he always says top 20
lines fool you're 15 he would always say
that you're 15. and then go John
[__] up and for like three years he did
he wouldn't and then one day I'm like
you want to try a line he just said [__]
it and I remember I was like I created a
monster the first time he did it I heard
his head came up and the smile he had I
went no you're hooked I felt bad but it
was like a friendly one we're not
sitting here
hey was anybody either dick suck for
some [__] drugs no I was never like
that no but there's I mean I can tell
you a time where it was in the middle of
the night and I'm like bro I have no
more drugs that sucks
hmm I would give all the weed I have
that's how far I'd go like I'd give all
the weed I have right now yeah and I
love wheat so that's not good
um
but the crack thing he bought a sack on
his own of crack no of coke calling his
own yeah and I was like hey that's a
little different you bought it on your
own you're not just doing it with me
yeah you got a sack oh no because he
knew my connect I'm like four blocks
from him
and then I remember he's like put it on
the ball go I hate that [__] my friends
do that I don't like it it tastes nasty
I don't want to smoke Coke on my weed
like
do this to do this no thanks I like
roller coasters I'm good
and uh he put it on he smoked it he went
oh come on man
I never smoking it right when I hit it
I hit it and then it smelled like color
crowns burning Jesus like Wax burning
yeah like but
I smelled it in here
I didn't just smell it in my head I'm
not even sure that's the proper way to
do crack because I think you just smoked
you just smoked it wasn't re-rocked or
anything no no no so as I'm smoking I'm
like oh gross this tastes disgusting I'm
like give me let me see it and that's
when I went are you [__] stupid and
that's when I went this isn't cocaine
he bought like a 40 50. and it was
rocked up it was yellow and a ball
chunks and shards yeah like like like
when soap starts to flake off of your
bar of soap when you're a kid right so
it wasn't cool it was [__] crack with
like there went here's some coke and
they just dusted it wow they [__]
and I looked at him like are you [__]
stupid so you didn't hit it and you
weren't like this is the greatest [__]
ever no I hit it I was like this tastes
like [__] and then I got a really really
bad headache
like uh one of these yeah like my head
was getting bigger than my head was and
I felt kind of like shaky or I just felt
wobbly and that's what I'm like give me
that let me let me see that [__] and
then we looked at it by lighter light or
the [__] you know what I mean and then
it was yellow little ball crunches like
I don't know how to describe it you know
what crack looks like yeah it looked
like crack for my seat for the movies
and when John for real
this is disgusting we're crackheads now
I hated it I'm glad I hated it though
like I tried oxy one time because John
my
dealer John okay not your uncle he was
stuck on oxy's bad this is obviously way
early in the in the game I'm assuming
fentanyl hadn't ruined a lot of people's
it was real bad actually [__] was crazy
she was crazy though he was popping them
like [__] Skittles bro it was really
really sad like it got to the point
where me and him were chilling every day
and I even really chill with my homie
that was his brother anymore because he
was like working doing she like I'll
chill with your brother I'm getting
packed from anyway
and it was just sad man because he's
such a good guy such a nice dude like he
could do anything he [__] wanted six
two blonde hair blue eyes like you have
to world at your palm fool come on he
just kept getting into [__] with
little gang bangers and he kept getting
into [__] with the Oxys and I
remember there got to a time where he
was so [__] up
where he wouldn't stop answering and he
wouldn't remember what I owed him and
I'm like I owe you that money oh yeah
yeah what did you take again and in my
head I'm like I could tell you two
pounds you gave me 20 piece oh wow I
could tell you anything right and you'd
be like oh gotcha bro I'm not a piece of
[__] I love that fool he's a chat like
he you know what I'm saying he's a good
person
and uh I remember I walked in once
and he was passed out like on the floor
partially on the couch there was like 60
peas laid out right in his walkway of
the house and the door is unlocked and I
just thought like what the [__] what the
[__] dude you know what I I could just
take it you're looking it's me who came
in that's what I told him when I woke
his ass up like it's lucky you're lucky
it's me somebody else would have pulled
up to try to see him they didn't [__]
eight yeah and he almost [__] Shot Me
One Time by accident he was asleep on
the couch with his little pistol when he
was going through the gangbanger [__]
and I knocked for 48 minutes straight I
needed the packs I'm like I'm just gonna
open the door and I yelled I yelled his
real name and he just went
and kind of like and I just kind of Dove
out the way a little into his kitchen
and I told him like I can't hang out
with you no more right stopped hanging
out with him like bro you you could have
killed me Jesus come on and then um
the last time I talked to him he got
robbed at a party why why would you
bring 30ps to a party I was so mad it
was like his Handler for a while but
like how old is this guy he's three
years older than me okay not much older
yeah but uh that was it this was the
last time I ever talked to him he
[__] disappeared that night after he
got robbed
his little puppy he just got his little
puppy and they found his puppy shot on
the road oh [__] right outside of town
and then
that's it I don't know what happened I
mean I know what happened a little
but he's been gone for like nine years
nowadays [__] I remember his mom was
putting like missing poster signs and
[__] it was really sad yeah [__] sucks
it was sad dude like it was really bad
he's still gone damn missing still
like two years ago someone said that
they found a body buried like outside of
town they're like could it be so and so
they kind of matches the age and [__]
I'm like [__] dude just tell me if it is
or not right you know are you still
friends with his little brother uh uh if
I got like eight homies six of them live
outside what type of [__] they're all
tweaking now so it's like oh it's like
when you say six of them out say like
they're homeless yeah yeah they live
outside oh [__] and uh in Merced in
Merced yeah I try to help his ass yeah
it just didn't work dude yeah did you
because I feel like we all kind of go
through a certain point in time where
we grow up around certain people or
we're related to certain people and you
gotta kind of
you know
not all family is family and not all you
know I I have homies in mind who like I
just outgrew them mentally or
yeah money's not even that like these
fools are just Tweakers outside it's
just like oh it's just it's not even
that bad like I wish it was like well
you got to grow up yeah cheat on your
girl or not taking care of your kid I
wish I wish my homies were just like
you gotta stop hitting your girl bro
like I'm gonna beat your ass again or
something I wish so it was at least like
I know you're alive right I only see my
friends through arrest reports bro and
it makes me so [__] sad my best homie
Joe my best my best [__] friend of
all time first time I talked to in 12
years I talked to him last Christmas I
started walking the streets
I see him always always by this time I'm
like you look happy and I talk to him
and like first time talking my best
[__] friend I chill with all day
every day we're gonna move in with right
because he was just too much he was
taking like too many pills mixing with
this he was getting drunk I just could
not be around his ass no more
he just lives under the bridge
with all these old fools Jesus and like
it's just made me [__] cry I couldn't
I couldn't believe it but I talked to
him recently and it like made my whole
year right he's doing better he looked
how he was doing better man he was
drinking a green juice oh okay he was
just walking down the street
and he didn't recognize me at first he
looked him and then he like we kind of
like I could see in his face that he was
just like oh my God right well [__] I
talked to his mom still right mom's
[__] amazing but she's like I can't
do anything for him anymore right
and
I now he's back doing [__] up [__]
because I just saw my homies like yo you
can send me the link just so I can check
up on my home
[__] how long he's gonna be oh [__] okay
then yesterday I word that for what I
was just talking about the podcast last
week one of my old homies I'm like I
walked I drove into town in my new car
I'm like I'm gonna take it to town and I
drove in and I just see one of my older
homies just twacked as [__] riding a
bike down the street just twacked and
then yesterday they told me he [__]
just died I didn't even know [__] so you
just saw him and I just saw him and
talked about him on the show the next
week he [__] dead what the [__]
overdose they're they're still trying to
determine it but how often do you go
back to Merced I used to go back a lot
but like four or five times a year now
yeah maybe a little more for birthdays
or something right right right right all
your family's still there your mom's
still there everybody yeah yeah and my
fiance's
family's from there too she's from there
okay cool right outside of town but yeah
Merced is like like you said earlier
it's kind of like it is a gang town like
there's yeah dude there's that whole
little pocket of Cali is active as [__]
yeah it's crazy like you wouldn't even
know it but it's easy to avoid stay in
your car go to [__] work don't talk
to [__] with gang face tattoos
right don't go buy drugs go don't be
doing [__] that drug dealers do right
don't go to the nightclub maybe don't go
to the bars with fools with big pants
nah for all this shit's real like go to
Applebee's and hang out yeah go to go
sing karaoke at Applebee's get half
price on your apps a hundred percent
right half price appetizers you can stay
out of it you can stay out of it full
say what are you looking at say sorry
I'm spacing out have a good day yeah you
don't have to check everybody that tries
to check like so many people be alive if
they just put their ego down slightly
and go I'm just got kids to take care of
and just kept walking 100 you can stay
at it you can stay out of this [__]
especially a small town small it's a
small town like we're GB gb's homies are
the homies I used to avoid growing up
you know I told them I even told him
because we just did a toy drive and
Merced at the gang Park but I grew up
right there because my grandma owns an
apartment building that touches the
fence so that's the park I grew up in
and I remember like
man there's a lot of gang banging
[__] out here I think I remember you
as a kid a hundred percent no no no I
don't remember him but no I mean like
his friends maybe oh for sure no a lot
of his homies I remember yeah
um but like I just told a story recently
um you know like a the potato gun
shotguns you ever see those so some fool
I just told the story like some fool
trying to take my [__] head off when
I was like 20
four I was getting food and full shot me
in the head with it like hoping to kill
my ass and just kept driving I just told
the story and I follow these fools to
12th Street where he beat all this
[__] always from I was like hey man I
just told a story about your street
isn't that crazy and then two days later
we do a toy drive on 12th Street that
I'm talking about at this park it's all
renovated with GB through this whole
city the [__] Soccer United Soccer
thing how to Booth I felt like not a
drug dealer for sure I felt so awesome
and GB just like he's making it happen
out there he's really making the town
like better and look better and all
these gang fools like yeah you could be
a gang banger
people around [__] be chill
everybody be cool pick up the trash like
this is our neighborhood like I [__]
love this fool for that dude and um
yeah I just it's active if if you're if
you're trying to be active right yeah I
think so what has been the uh because I
I when I checked out your YouTube
channel there was like your most viewed
interviews were people who I had no idea
who they were which I was always which I
loved I was like this is dope right so I
like I just like kind of dived into a
few of the interviews like the Goblin
guy he's great and um the fulcrum guy
yeah so so I didn't know who a lot of
these because again like I'm oblivious
to your world bro this world is is uh
I like to think of it as the next big
thing and it's I've been doing it
exactly for 10 years
and I think we're just at half a percent
on the way there like you're just barely
scraping the oh man possibility even
start no one's made a billion yet yeah
like no weed kid has made a billion
dollars off the weed yet and when it
happens
I just I just want to be right next to
him like I'm just like yeah I think what
burn will be the first guy probably
right probably yeah or
or some dude that never [__]
well this was in the in the industry but
like was in the background there's some
people
um I know a few people are very very
close yeah yeah it's probably the same
people we're thinking 100 yeah it's
gonna be same dude or same two dudes
yeah yeah yeah there's probably this
dizzy guy and then the uh I think
stizzy's too split between too many
owners for one person and then my boy
alex
you know Alex Armenian Alex okay well
he's doing well he's the guy behind all
the cookie stores oh yeah uh I'm pretty
sure they're in the green thumb they
live across the street for me
I just moved into a spot and my name was
like the cookies people the guys I was
like damn that's a fat [__] houses
yeah there's two houses next to each
other yeah but yeah no I moved to this
new spot and just like I'm very low-key
right but it's very weird like I'm
walking I follow this [__] I'm
driving into my garage closing my garage
I'm not talking to nobody but it's like
a very wild neighborhood I'm looking
around like I
it's crazy it's [__] great cause I'm
like I'm from Merced I'm so [__]
excited like I'm just happy like I can't
believe that [__] works so for you
obviously the podcast is very successful
yeah it hasn't been the easiest thing
for you to monetize because of the [__]
YouTube [__] right no so now you're
moving into taking on sponsorships that
you probably before were turning down
because you wanted to play play ball
with YouTube Right Spotify made us
partners they're putting us on the front
we're gonna be like the
for this month we're gonna be like the
show to watch or whatever they're going
to play as the ad that pops up so I'm
hyped dude Spotify they made his brand
partners and [__] and uh
we get really good views on Spotify and
Spotify we asked them like what about
the Wii they go do whatever you want
they don't give a [__] and he said show
anything like as long as you're not
being hateful are you racist are you are
you able to have the videos on you on
Spotify oh see that's dope and there so
if we get the comments it's because
we've been pushing them for comments on
live premieres so we're talking to them
and they're going to see if they can
integrate I wonder if they've done that
yet no they haven't no no we we asked
him for it yeah like well nobody really
asked but I go we'll be the guinea pigs
Marty's really good with this Tech [__]
so he's like hey we should implement
this this and this we have the meeting
and that's why they gave us video
they hit us up like you guys do really
well but YouTube man like
the G-Eazy episode was one of the lowest
views episodes of anything we've ever
done why it was such a good conversation
it's [__] she easy and I look in the
back end and everything is like one
percent one percent recommended one
percent home like they don't push our
[__] and it's age restricted how they do
on Spotify
I think it doubled that the first week
yeah I think I think too like
it's crazy well I think I think your
guys's audience is like very unique man
I feel like they're Die Hard they're die
hard but they're also
like I said when I looked at your most
viewed like I was like go I I love to
discover new [__] right so I was kind of
excited to find your podcast and then
like for a couple of days I really was
like yo who's this guy and I watched
some no jumper interviews and and um I
didn't realize that there was this
YouTube world of weed content creators
there's there's not a lot and the ones
that are doing it well you saw yeah and
the reason why they bring those views is
we are it's like going to the Cannabis
Cup and bringing a famous basketball
player like oh my God there's gonna be a
small crowd of dudes like whoa yo can I
get a picture
go to the Cannabis Cup and Tommy Chong
walks in it's like it's different oh
[__] it's a direct it's like Target
marketing right it's different it's
direct Goblin has a good weed following
we brought on the show we just had a
great conversation he's such a good dude
and it blew up because our fans and his
fans both all at the same time let's
watch this and do and it just
we have that many fans so every one of
us games wow
yeah telling stories so he tells stories
and does chose gameplays no he does game
play over it you're watching the
gameplay yeah because he's monetized
right he's so smart the audio you're
hearing is the so smart man he tells me
every time I get demonetize I'll read a
children's book as the whole video I get
remonetized oh my God he's the [__]
man he's like what book should I get my
monetization back for him and he'll post
that [__] he's the man he's moving out
here next month man I'm really excited
to interview that guy he's great you
should he's [__] awesome
um the biggest ones are we people
because that's that's us well that's
your guys's that's our audience man and
it's such a
on uh it hasn't you're like your lane
hasn't been hoared out yet no people are
trying but I think our as to where I
feel like the weed game itself is a
little weird out for sure but the Wii
content game is very still I always said
like it's just we're waiting for one
world-class photographer director to
come [__] with this
industry
and we'll have a new nice stream so
we'll have a new [__] Cheech and
Chong genre we're gonna have everything
that anybody can think of
look how successful super bad our
Pineapple Express was it's a cult
classic it's a cult class I mean also
like you have to find somebody who will
take risks with that kind of content now
because I was just talking to the homies
about comedies and you could probably
attest to this we haven't had like a
classic comedy and a while it's been
like 10 Years bro in a while Tropic
Thunder was great Tropic Thunder was
amazing but they couldn't make that
movie today no but that's why it was one
of the last really really hard-hitting
ones Jack Black was [__] feeding for
heroin and he ate the bird I said it's
crazy come on but it really is going to
take somebody who's got the bankroll to
do it the right way
and do it without worrying are we gonna
make money on this or not are we going
to try to start a trend beginning to the
first Cheech and child movies were not
boxed office hits and they were low
budget yeah they were low budget grew
over the years Friday DJ Friday come on
man those posted on a very small budge
DJ I think he said he filmed it on a
black the black box the part two on a
black box
a lot of the comedian dudes are trying
to eventually come together and and and
try to you know do that because
we need good comedy we need R-rated real
R-rated [__] bruh yeah any issue that
you have to like yo you should get the
kid out of the room this would be great
we need like an Animal House
of today like something that's just like
even even like some [__] like Borat
which obviously
whatever Borat is not one of those I
don't look at it in that same realm but
I love Borat but it's like this [__]
naked dudes running around it's funny
that fat old man puts his ass in dude's
face and his balls are on his chin and
I'm just like where's that at and listen
I'm not looking for this where's that at
I'm not looking for that this is a wild
clip right there but I'm saying like I
just need the real crazy the real crazy
comedy I'm like man I don't even know
what like when I go to the movies
anymore it's like
it's always superhero [__] Bro otherwise
I'm just waiting for it to hit the
streaming services you're not wrong it's
like at all I saw Barbie with my wife oh
I didn't see that was it at least funny
it was all right bro it was whatever
I've been watching some trash movies
lately too I hear what your girl
probably like Barbie it's a good movie
um it was good it wasn't like and it you
don't have to be like a girly girl like
it was like a good movie it's always a
good movie I don't care it's a good
movie it's a very unique movie it was a
unique movie yeah like the thing is with
my girl she's she's just me she's me
with she's just a girl right well that's
great we're the uh
that's my best friend so
when I think of a moon like she's gonna
[__] hate this because I hate this
right because I already know how you're
gonna think like I already know it hey
will you text TK to shut the [__] up
thank you she knows voice that is that's
[__] TK bro yo TK shut the [__] up
Jesus you little string you pull through
the door call this [__] and a
thing that goes on in there who is he
talking to bro like what is TK doing in
there alone is he is he's [__] live
streaming from his [__] like what is
happening in there it's not outside no
no this is uh there's a whole like
kitchen no it's coming from in there I
hear his [__] voice tell that
[__] to shut the [__] up
Jesus Christ TK's [__] bail ogre
voice
penetrating these thin walls from this
old Asian Trap House apparently yeah no
that's exactly what it was which is
great though it really makes it
authentic we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our folks
at my bookie man look my bookie NFL
season is approaching and you know what
they just added that I love is that
early cash out let's say you got a
ticket and it's looking great you can
cash out early on that ticket all right
I love it all right plus of course my
bookie's got the full casino going down
and if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg they will give you
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars all right so head over
to my bookie ASAP um look we're at uh
NFL coming there's baseball you can
gamble on right now and of course the
full service casino blackjack with the
real dealer uh roulette craps whatever
you're into slot machines you could do
it and cash out right on my bookie all
right all you got to do is sign up with
that new promo code bootleg when you
sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg at kingpom.com and uh man trust
me the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpom.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview I was
going to ask you like uh
how do you see because you know we we
see a guy like Berner who just made the
Forbes Magazine cover we see uh the weed
industry obviously there's been a lot of
people who have come in and I feel like
with just money intention that aren't
necessarily I mean I think of a guy like
Jay-Z who never smoked weed never rapped
about smoking weed and he comes in
starts a weed brand I think it's already
gone away I don't think anyone's smoking
the JC pack respectfully
um but on the content side right like
would you kind of consider yourself to
be like kind of like
The Joe Rogan lead game
um and do you see like where do you see
that your Niche your world going like
because it's only going to get bigger
right and there is going to be Outsiders
trying to come in yeah so the way I see
it is like
my biggest [__] I'm like Bob Ross with
weed like I could teach you anything and
make you not feel like you're lame for
not knowing that [__] nice because you
shouldn't like I see homies make fun of
fools that can't hit bombs like they've
never hit a bong
teach this person right right like I
have homies at my age can you roll it
you roll better and I taught you how to
roll a joint before I did videos like
just do this all right let's do it in my
homie one of my my business partner my
best friends
I taught him how to roll so our our [__]
is I think our content will help you in
any aspect if you don't know what you're
doing maybe learn some new [__] see the
newest stuff or like the
the underground QVC when it comes to
reviews on fire you know I'm like yo I'm
only putting [__] on the show that's
tight and I'll review it or do you get
paid to do reviews it depends okay
man that's a great way to monetize yeah
I just want to grow the channel I just
want more people to see because why they
might buy a shirt they might watch a
podcast they might because I have
another brand I don't know if I don't
even talked about it uh the dopest shop
the dopa shop is you know what uh Tec
alternatives are alternative
cannabinoids you know like I've heard of
I mean I've heard yeah so you know I'm
sure you've heard of Delta eight yeah
it's like the legal weed that they can
ship you everybody calls a diet weed or
that's like the [__] that like if like
gummies are sold everywhere it's because
it's got the Delta eight in it thank you
so we don't do Delta a because Delta a
is very unpredictable I feel so we do
something called hhc is it kind of like
uh the new spice people try to say that
that haven't smoked it or I think
just don't try to categorize it all
together because what it is is my
partner he's he owns a company called
Hash House it's like one of the bigger
right names in the hash industry he came
at me because he knows I'm a [__]
snob with weed and [__] oh I finally
heard yo call Alexis
I finally hit go go do it do it do it
he's out here
yo shut the [__] up
Jesus Christ bro these [__] jerk offs
in there and they're jerking each other
off about to record music
tell them to go to the [__] Studio
sorry my artist you have a couple a
couple studios here you do five yeah you
showed me you're gonna shoot the [__] go
shoot the [__] in the room you're about
to [__] record sorry you're gonna
like go follow Alexis Alexis wrote it on
Instagram he's a piece of [__]
um anyway so continue with with the the
shop because so oh yeah so my friend
approached me and he says hey uh I have
this idea he has his homie does CBD big
CBD manufacturer producer yay and I was
like uh okay no because uh fools do that
everyone makes for the CBD oh hell no
CBD if you like it go smoke it we don't
do CBD but uh what I was saying is he
approached me I'm like bro you want me
to do a
I'm not a THC brand like right come on
dude he's like no it's AJC it gets you
high go don't [__] lie to me because
she knows I'm like don't try to [__]
lie to me went to his house and I ate
1200 milligrams of the Edibles I'm like
I need to see if this [__] works I
want to I want to do at least a thousand
but there are bombs you know I ate a
couple more it turned out to be 12. I
hit the pens and I'm ripping pens and
I'm like okay it's a pen
it's a pen like okay
I got him a uber and just started
getting so violently [__] high
instead so you were spinning really I
almost asked my Uber to pull over so I
could throw up
I was right more than that you were just
trying so many of them well I just
wanted to know I I eat thousands of
milligrams of THC I know how I'm gonna
feel
and like the five to the 5 000
milligrams of THC video and I was just
really tired wait you ate 5 000 yeah
like when I say oh my channel I do mad
challenges like I smoked what popped my
YouTube off as I smoked a 40 gram joint
in one sitting no water no nothing
looked at the camera for two and a half
hours smoked that whole [__] thing
down because somebody said I would I
wouldn't do it oh no I saw a bunch of
YouTubers like smoking a zip right holy
[__] I'm like he didn't smoke is it by
yourself and they didn't so my [__]
I'm gonna do it by myself and I'll get
in real time in real time didn't move
and every that video popped off I was
like damn this wolf really did smoke
that oh my God and I really I mean you
watch it I uh it was the worst I caught
up tar and [__] for like like two months
probably oh my God it was bad it hurts
[__] yeah I was just tight it was fire
ass OG packs that I was getting at the
time too so I was very happy about that
and uh
so anyway I tried I'm spinning because
my 1200 milligrams did that [__] to me
oh no
like well [__] I get to my house and I
call I'm like yo find me some more
products I'll try it again and then if
this works I'm down
and then I just remember like I got so
violently High I'm ripping the pens I
mean the Edibles like this got me [__]
up but I gave it to a friend he goes I
feel nothing of 500 milligrams because
some people don't metabolize THC either
well that happens with shrooms it
happens with Marty trims don't hit him
yeah I have my wife like we went and you
know out I love shrooms I have a shroom
gummy brand and oh nice yeah what's the
uh mushroom you're using uh we use a 70
albino penis envy 30 albino Avery
mushroom yeah
yeah yeah I thought you made like legal
ones I just ship them out like I don't
know why me you know uh the shrooms
though obviously I know I have people in
my life like my wife will eat a ton of
[__] mushrooms and she'll be like I
don't feel anything and I'm like what
I'm [__] stuck yep Marty that's Marty
I like two Grands like I don't feel it
yet and then we got some real good ones
and they frocked him during an episode
so
wait if the first time already felt it
was during an episode which was wild
which is crazy yeah we got it all
together and uh so I told my yo this
works and then we started a brand the
dopashop.com do the first day I was in
my head I had a number like if we could
hit this number this Brand's gonna be
good we hit that [__] in an hour really
oh my God we're number three on Earth
for any alternative brand so this is an
alternative essentially you can sell it
legally wherever door to door are you we
ship it straight we just started because
do shops carry that [__] yeah [__] yeah
we just started wholesale because we
were doing so well retail like dude why
put in so much money to make a fourth of
what we're making every two minutes
because on online we can ship to all 50
states so we have blunts pre-rolls
syrups I got some [__] for you too okay
the serves I think are just too strong
yeah honestly I believe I never got into
the see eating weed is uh rough for me
these Edibles are they're they're strong
they are but my wife likes Edibles I I
I'll give you the ones with hash yes we
have hash in them too I [__] I've had
the worst highs of my life eating weed
I mean the worst dude I blacked out I'd
rather eat too much shrooms than eat too
much oh no I'm the opposite I've eaten
too much rooms before
I like you eat a lot of mushrooms what's
your what's your go-to what are you
doing when you're trying to trip are you
just micro dosing no I usually usually
I'll micro dose right but sometimes
um I just like to [__] eat a ton of
shrooms to sit in my hot tub at night
in the water yeah and this play Tame
Impala
do you float ever yes oh
oh my God bro and then I just like yeah
that's the best I love that I do a
Jacuzzi Jacuzzi night time and then I
got my jacuzzis got the like colorful
lights and [__] oh you're having a great
time it's [__] amazing I think the
heat would get me and I start tripping
because there's always a point of where
I get a little nervous a little scared
and then I go take off yeah I've had
some really bad I've had one really bad
trip and that was in Austin Texas and I
met so my friend is a rapper named
Freddie Gibbs and he went on Joe Rogan's
podcast yeah I watched the clip last
night and uh I was uh I went with him
out there and um
I get to hang out with Joe Rogan who's
like is a big reason why I started
eating shrooms because he would always
talk about the benefits and [__] and so
me and Freddie ate too much but we did
it in front of Joe Rogan because I was
like hey bro I brought some shrooms from
Cali
it was backstage at kill Tony at this
[__] that's the clip I watched when
he you you're lucky [__] yeah
this was prior to but that was
Philadelphia no no but but I know what
you're talking about when Freddie no but
that was like uh this was like a year
before that
um but yeah so
I was like Hey Joe you want some like
you're kind of the reason he's like bro
I gotta plan my [__] and I was like it's
all good man I [__] paid my I ate too
much and then we went have you ever been
to Austin no oh so we go to sixth and uh
which is like just this street uh just
nothing but music venues and bars the
whole [__] Street it's a legendary
place
and dude I was just tripping balls the
whole time man I all [__] everyone's
face looked like remember back in the
day used to watch Cops and their faces
used to be pixelated for everyone's
faces look like they were on Cops bro
that's incredible I thought
[__] were following us I
thought they were gonna try to kill us I
snuck out the back of a bar bro and I
don't even know how the [__] I ended up
in my room I just remember calling my
wife
and being like I have no idea what's
happening I'm trying to find where my
hotel is
and she was like super worried and then
I just hung up on her and then I woke up
the next day oh she wasn't tripping all
night yeah she was not happy you know I
gotta be honest that's not a bad trip
story no no you're right I haven't had
like the trip where I'm like no that's a
great trip story no it's a story for
sure you're like one of my words my
worst trip in my life was on Edibles
though oh yeah you're saying the Edibles
was bad like oh Joe Rogan you know and
an awesome ass man that was pretty good
that's the worst that's the worst time
I've had on shrooms in terms of just me
freaking out now eating weed is terrible
I blacked that off a few times at an
event I blacked out I've puked I mean I
went to it [__] Yelawolf Ritz concert
and I had a whole I think I had like a
250 uh gram [__] uh Brownie and I
have you ever been so high that you feel
like you have superpowers
or your senses are heightened a hundred
percent on the heightened senses because
I can hear everything oh my God that's
what happened I'll be like I heard this
full his phone however far away they are
from a mile away yes I heard this bro
people I was at an event
working my own booth
too [__] up and you can hear it all I
can hear it all and that's the one thing
I always thought like why can't I hear
everything and and your heartbeat what
kind of makes you think to yourself like
we're not using our full capabilities
because if you eat too much weed you can
hear everything it was not like I was
tripping I could physically hear bro I'm
in the light on over there I'm in the
middle I'm in the middle of a concert my
feet are like planted into the cement I
couldn't walk
and I'm just looking around and honing
in on everyone's conversation in the
middle of a concert and hearing them
perfectly
it was [__] incest awesome I gotta be
honest that's crazy you have great trips
and then Garfield the cat was on stage a
cartoon version of him and his eyeballs
were spinning like a slot machine
and then do just the craziest [__] like
the [__] that would happen in front of
somebody who was tripping balls
The Coincidence of it happening while I
was tripping balls was happening like I
had some Native American dude come up to
me and start like barking in my ear
about how we stole his country and [__]
and I thought it wasn't real you got
[__]
hated on Mid tripping bro the dude was
like was he real he's like hey white boy
hey you stole my land bro it was
literally that and I was just like that
to me and I couldn't walk and my boy Geo
was like a big Puerto Rican dude I look
at Geo and I said is this [__]
real he's like yeah he's real you want
me to [__] knock him out I was like
no
and I was like bro I'm sorry bro I don't
know you bro like I was like I think I'm
native too a little you know like it was
a rough night and then I ended up puking
all over the place
yo you should just be sitting here
telling the store do you do solo episode
I don't know you should really just
speak into that camera because that
we're gonna start doing we're gonna
start doing different [__] story that
was [__] hilarious you stole my land
yeah dude it was crazy shout out to uh
yellow wolf and Ritz that was a
legendary Night
yes [__] the Edibles man I can't do it
they always make me puke I don't know
really see the thing with me like
my mom and dad were both on drugs when I
was a kid and then I found out on the
podcast that my mom and dad were both on
acid the night I was made oh and I think
that's I have an insane memory I don't
know if we talked about this
is [__] annoying nice it's very
annoying like I think I have 80d because
I have that Tame Impala song that when
you mention them it's been playing in my
head the whole time since we've been
talking which one it's the it's the uh
uh come on it's like my favorite [__] is
let it happen it's number two on my list
if you ever get high I know what it
sounds like play let it happen and just
the [__] sound like switches from
like the left and right ear dude that
let it happen by Tame Impala is the best
[__] I just found out who they were a
year and a half ago bro me too yeah I
didn't know I was missing this whole
genre
really it's not a band it's a one dude
he produces everything and sings
I thought I saw a live oh yeah they
perform and he has he'll he'll hire the
band oh [__] oh [__] what a talented
Paul is a single human being
I didn't know that he makes all the
Beats plays all the instruments and then
helps people do them live so you can do
live shows yeah that's [__]
incredible actually I didn't know that
100 wow I always say they a dude I
always say they one dude it's one guy
yeah I didn't know that until maybe like
six months ago on a trip me the [__] out
I found out about 30 seconds ago oh dude
that's just so much music happening in
his songs like he's like hey play and
then you can go on like YouTube and see
him make the songs
like tame Impala's a beast I don't even
know his real name is it's like uh do
you watch YouTube and stuff all the time
see I don't watch anything yeah and I
told you I hurt my back this weekend so
I have been by myself in my room
watching YouTube yeah algorithm I feed
you what you want right no I've been
learning about podcast stuff I've never
watched really other podcasts like fully
right I didn't know there was so much
drama between all these huge comedians
oh yeah it's great holy [__] I didn't
know what A.D and Adam were mad at you
right now yeah you know I have no idea
what that's going I know and I'm in
podcasts good for you by the way that's
Scott that's great and then I watched a
clip it goes y-a-d and Adam 22 are mad
each and I went
how did I not know any of these things
dude the comedian [__] is the best I
just found out about all that there's
like there's like the YouTube uh like
the guys that break it down yes that's
who I was watching it's like the Indian
guy yeah and the hair yeah I've been
watching for two days straight dude I
swear to watch I watched it breaks
everything now he's like such a good way
he's like the [__] Charles Barkley
and Kenny Smith have like [__] is so
good that I found out about all of Bobby
Lee's stuff all of his body shit's crazy
I had no idea about any of this stuff oh
yeah I I don't know how I'm so ignorant
uh Bert Kreischer like where they like
have this like Awakening on the show why
they're not allowed while they're
cooking or were you talking about their
agents yes that's the one I watched uh
the last night too so it was crazy bro
and then you see the box then there's
the Bobby Lee Brennan job I didn't know
about any of this stuff Marty's was
Marty uh
just took like started like letting go
of guests yeah of his of his clients
because our show like we we needed that
we needed him for that yeah and he
doesn't work with anybody anymore except
I think Ryan sickler he helps them with
stuff and it's just all us now but Marty
was like the little guy doing all these
little ticket things and sales and
targeted marketing for all these guys
and then now he's just doing it on our
end which is why I think the back end
helps it's starting to pump a little bit
because we're trying to find fans that
are not in the weed world because I mean
do we talk about everything
but when it comes to all the podcast
drama I had no idea it's crazy I didn't
know that existed like there's a lot of
it
it's pretty wild I had no idea I had
doodle on never even asked about the
atom [__] I had no idea why they left I
didn't know anything and I was like I'm
gonna smoke a joint I'm gonna go about
my day because I don't it's not my drama
I don't care and I learned about it I
went I still don't care but now that I
know at least now I like am more
knowledgeable on the [__] that right
look I mean I do this every day I live
in the same city as these humans I don't
know what's going on right right I don't
want you it's pretty wild it is pretty
wild who's your number one requested
guest you haven't had on yet Joey Diaz
um that'd be sick yeah Joey Diaz and uh
well
requested like by the fans not over and
over and over
I would say Joey Diaz
in the terms of Comedy
would run in the weed side on the weed
side
like you guys haven't had burner on have
you no we have that burner on
I guess Cheech and Chong together get
asked a lot
because I don't get a lot of weed people
asking me first Joey Diaz would be dope
but you might have to go to New Jersey I
was over there and we're supposed to do
it and then he had a movie uh I was
there for like four days in New York
he's just doing a lot of stories he's
incredible he just watched his his story
about how he kidnapped a dude and went
to prison for it oh we got in trouble
yeah I just watched the nun one it makes
me laugh everywhere beating that up he's
hilarious it's so funny he's just it's a
storytelling is what I love dude I think
everybody does they watch movies right
listen to music would you accommodate
I think because that's really what
comedy is right yeah people that I get a
lot of that uh we we interview Brian
Callan right and I was telling Marty I
have a bunch of [__] written for my ears
I have a lot of stuff written
and uh
I was talking to him he's like I think
you should do that I was like really go
stop saying you should and just go do
this [__] and then Josh was like your
timing is great you should probably try
it at least but yeah I guess so and
identify some of your stories and then
figure out how to make them work on
stage well the thing is like if I do I
know it's going to be a storytelling
thing but it could be jokes too but I
feel like it's going to be like a weave
yeah there's like uh Ali Sadiq whose
storytelling is [__] incredible and
then obviously the guy like Brooke
Chrysler his whole [__] life change
from changing the machines yeah you know
so yeah dude yeah you should do it yeah
I told Marty like two weeks ago I last
episode I actually did a couple of my
things on there maybe but I
this is my thing dude like I I'm really
nice and all that [__] but all the [__]
I say is so vulgar and some of the [__]
I say might make it 90 of you really
upset but also
that's a good ten percent that's
laughing but that's wow that's the good
[__] yeah yeah I want people to go
yo you're right like I know him right
just think about it in the terms of the
I think it's like uh Jerry Seinfeld if
he smoked weed slash Joey Diaz
storytelling is where I would go I'm
like yo I'm just gonna tell you
observations [__] you probably didn't
see I bet you too like if you have you
ever done the story time thing live no
that would be that would be that's a
basically stand up that's what I mean
that could be that could be kind of your
version of getting your foot into that
door where you're a little more
comfortable on stage Marty and I are
your fans we're supposed to do at the
end of the year but we're the Laugh
Factory we're supposed to do a live
little thing that's like 200 people and
uh the there's one it's one of the
comedy stores or one of the comedy spots
and that's I think how we're going to do
I'm just going to open up with like 10
minutes of [__] I wrote and then me and
Marty gonna start I think that's how I
start to get more comfortable because
I'm not worried about like Freddie Gibbs
uh Freddie gives hilarious my boy but he
just he's funny bro well he just started
doing like uh stand up spot stand-ups it
is cocaine comedy me and Marty actively
talk about Freddie Gibbs we actually
talk about all these artists that we
love because they're [__] awesome but
Freddie Gibbs comes up a lot because
he's just so damn funny bro he's
hilarious he's just a funny human being
once you just just speak yeah just speak
he's just a comedian whenever he does
whenever he does his uh his next run
I'll make sure he comes on your [__] let
us know bro that'd be that'd be awesome
he's just a funny ass fool and like I
said I was watching The Kill Tony with
him last night
there's a there's a lane there for that
guy for sure you know what I mean for
sure definitely
um all right so kill trees is is your
clothing line push trees let's kill Tony
you see what I did I know I know what
you did kill trees
push trees not kill Toady push trees is
your clothing line yeah push trees
that's been is would you say that the
clothing what what for you is kind of
surpassed like your number one like
Breadwinner in terms of like your shop
ah
wow so it's doing that wow
well I saw what you drove up it's
life-changing you drove up in a [__]
a big boy that thing do people know what
you drive I don't want to take what
you're driving yeah I'm sure they do
okay yeah if you post it it's almost no
it's on my page okay [__] guy pulled
up in her Maybach I love that thing dude
so that opportunity which is a newer
opportunity yeah changed your life yes
because I every time money I put I put
right back in the car it's expensive to
make for all these videos and like to
pay for editing and then all the stuff
and the filming is it gets expensive I
mean sometimes are eight hours but
they're a 15 minute video that b-roll is
six hours straight us doing the lights
there's lazy Susans having them because
I like I want you to feel like I have a
commercial but damn this is YouTube so a
lot of my reviews are so interesting
okay we get that long ass lens that
shoots into stuff do you follow that one
dude on YouTube who Peter detect [__]
Peter McKenna no no the black dude who
reviews all the tech [__] what's his
name oh the guy does the number one dude
I [__] watch all his videos
you're like the weed version of that
yeah that's cool he'll do like [__]
these most the most intricately shot
reviews of everything that's Tech all
cinematic and [__] dude synonym that's
what I want from the top yeah yeah
crazy angles [__] going by about all
these crazy lights we have all our
lights in the roof and [__] it's just
fun but
it's it's for the dope like I was doing
fine I just I started I never made any
money off any content until end of 2019.
wow man I could never never didn't right
push trees just kept me afloat and then
I decided just to invest all my time
into just making as much content as I
can and see if a company might want to
pay for something and then it happened
it worked a few times and then it just
became normal and that helped me pay for
the podcast because I funded everything
the warehouse everything for the podcast
if I started we started that and then we
as we made money you know kind of paid
it back but then I have like I started
another brand with my friend we have
another Warehouse not far from here yeah
and it's like the Walmart for weed
products like we have King Palm we have
everything every weed thing you know
like head shop but online oh nice I do
videos for those companies right let's
do a video for me and I'm gonna own this
[__] because I feel like I can do so
much more so you have like a online
retail the reupstore.com oh nice yeah
it's dope we just we just officially
like relaunched it's doing well and then
you're the the man to promote your own
[__] straight to your fan base so now
yeah dude from you then grab from you
know whoever Amazon or exactly and um
for post trees like I said it's about to
hit the year 10. I feel like we just
been kind of weed shirts for a while
but recently I'm not I can talk about it
you know mine but I recently hired a
creative director and he's the one that
helped start V loan and revenge
so he's gonna he's he's fully made me
think different shout out to my homie
Jay try to expand the clothing [__] just
not even expand bro like just
he's just gonna he's just crushing
everything for us man we're no longer
just like a shirt company our news our
drop that we just did was relatively
small and it sold faster than anything
I've ever done and it's the first time
it wasn't just a
funny design black shirt like we had
wow and we have models and photographers
and [__] I've never done it's always
been me my phone right snapping for nine
and a half years just trying to sell it
now it's it's like oh this is a real
thing you could get into [__] Zoomies
or oh just oh that's just bad like the
collabs that we're working on right now
or I'll tell you off okay but [__]
[__] I wear this [__] my whole life
he's he's taking it to
I'm like what did you reload let's do
that for us
and blow this [__] up and the next drops
coming out is
is full-on clothing company like I feel
like I can have a store on Fairfax with
just this right the feeling that I'm
getting from these is so much different
than anything I've ever done man what's
the website where people can push
trees.com push trees he's just and then
where can people buy
the
cannaboid [__] the uh oh the
dopashop.com no uh yeah the dopashop.com
that's the number one
our fan it's just what it was the reason
yeah and then re-up shop the rehab
store.com do we have we have there's a
lot of stuff going on yeah but uh push
trees cannabis launches at the end of
the year that's safe our facilities are
done so that's gonna be like a grow or
is that going to be
yeah yeah everything yes manufacturing
volatile license we're we're ready to go
man we're going to be fully I'm just
like if we didn't have another interview
very shortly I would we could go for
like another hour and a half go for it
um thank you for having me no we gotta
wait how long we've been here it's been
about 30. it's been about an hour hour
well yeah yeah about an hour 40. yeah
yeah it feels like it I don't know it's
just it's weird being on the other side
of I'll do many other shows I appreciate
you pulling up man thank you I gotta
come check out your spot too where are
you guys come film at over here
somewhere we're kind of well it was kind
of close to Burbank yeah we're on the
right outside of Burbank Valley yes no
not the valley we're right outside of
Burbank on the other side and closer to
Glendale but we're I mean we're moving
next the next month I think nice we're I
just need a new bigger spot for the
clothes are killing we do the congrats
like I said dude I'm glad you came up
bro because I was like oh thanks man I
feel like man this dude we [__] get
along like our childhoods are very
similar yeah it's just uh you have to
think about it people ask you like are
you you're not [__] up from that like
I could be if I want to let it I could
you could have let it happen yeah
everybody in my family is [__] up
except me and my sister she's doing all
right you know what I mean I feel you
man yeah yeah but you know it's crazy my
parents are in town right now and it was
like
my I just you know shout out to them
they're they're they're doing well but
my dad was down
certain times same like I had a [__]
drug dealers one time I remember vividly
as a kid
my apartment complex fools came looking
for my dad and my mom was like
he owes that money and I was like [__]
not good not good some step that my step
doesn't [__] happened like that but not
over that not over drugs some other [__]
yeah no we gotta we gotta chop it up
some more man I appreciate you pulling
up appreciate you thank you sir yes sir
that was an awful thank you it was very
up it's okay we got through it
appreciate you man thank you hey what up
man uh you just watched another episode
of the bootleg cab podcast brought to
you by hard Dean baby shout out to the
family at hard Dean don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
Jardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Hardin in Las Vegas
the number one dispensary in the world
all right and we are so proud to be
partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Hardy and
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine